all right James yes James where you from
originally I'm originally from Louisiana
shareport Louisiana shareport yes tell
me about your family growing up well I
didn't have a big family I had a I had a
sister and a brother and uh they
deserted my mom deserted their kids so I
mean we all separated I still haven't
seen my sister and
brother and um it hurts but life do go
on
how would you describe your
childhood um up and down I I was able to
I was able to get into a good foster
care and then I ran away and then they
put me in another one that wasn't that
good it was
abusive so I mean um pretty much my
childhood was up and down like I just
said and
um it hurts to think back on it because
some stuff happened in my second foster
care and then during my life it's it has
been
repeated can I ask what happened in that
second foster care
um it hurts to say but I
was violently
molested
and you are the first person I ever told
us to honestly you're the first person I
ever told us to really yes you carry the
secret with you go I cared the secret
for
almost 50
years not knowing what the outcome would
be but I mean if somebody else can hear
my story and I can help them be to be
able to to tell their story faster and
sooner I mean it's a lot of programs now
that can help these people that has been
molested and uh that's scared to to
speak out on
it
so um this is my
story and that went on for how long
pardon me how long did that go on it
went on for about three years then I ran
away and
uh it it it it stopped but I grew up
being a bisexual
man and
um you came to Los Angeles I came to Los
Angeles
in
like
7879 and by me coming out here the first
place I went to Hollywood so it was
bizarre Hollywood was
um a second home for me so to speak cuz
people used to pick me up off the street
and uh we would do homosexual
things until I I actually I actually
graduated from high school then once
that happened I mean
my life
turned to to the worst I was introduced
to downtown Los Angeles and uh oh boy I
thought I mean I thought that me being
molested
was something
natural but then when I came to Los
Angeles
Hollywood did downtown it was totally
totally a freak Show for real it was a
real freak
Show and it hurts it still hurts to
think about how I was introduced to
downtown you know it was the drug
scenery uh fast
money
until till I got caught up you know I
got caught up by the police
um it was it was it was crazy it it it
hurts
now to really talk about it because I
still can see the demons and the people
that had done me wrong
uh I soon got over it though I got over
it by
meditating and practi practicing Buddha
you know buh ISM and
um now that I'm speaking about it it
really it really it really kind of
releases a lot of pressure off me but I
know what had happened
and it's not going to change you know
it's not going to change but uh but I
think that that information has power
over you if you keep it a secret yes it
most definitely has the power but now
that I I released it I released it and
that I'm being
televised it it it can help somebody
else do you feel lighter yes I I really
do I really do I mean I thought that by
me speaking on it I was going to feel I
was going to cry and and boohoo well
um I needed to talk about this bro I
really do I believe it um it's a hell of
a secret to keep inside the hell of a
secret for the simple fact that I I was
molested I was I was
was I was pretty much raped and Men
Can't don't think that they can be raped
but I was raped not once not twice but
several times in my life and but all of
was in my teenager years so so I
mean I can talk about it I don't want to
talk about it but it's it's done now and
um I can move on so to speak I can
really move on and uh
get out of the mess that I'm I'm in
still still to this day 2023 I mean I'm
I was haunted Behind these these uh
noises these these sounds men men the
mustaches and beards on me you
know it's it's it's it's crazy it's
really crazy
and I'm ready I'm ready to to move on
I'm ready to for the next chapter in my
book that's great you know drugs have
been a part of your life drugs been
somewhat of problem as me being young um
I'm almost three years clean
now and
uh that's that's a good thing in my life
cuz because at first I was selling my
body actually selling my body you know
like I was some type of
freak but now that I know I'm not no
freak I didn't tell my sponsor the story
I'm telling you guys they say in a big
book you got to get clean you got to you
got to get rid of all the junk that's in
your past but this a story that I I
didn't want nobody to know you know I
don't know you you don't know me so I
figured that this would be a good time
for me to
broadcast my story you know I know
somebody somebody that want to watch
this will
definitely it would definitely help
them you know I believe that yeah I
truly believe it too you
know um but now my life alone but now my
life is is starting to turn
around I mean this this is even goingon
to make it better you know I could tell
myself that I was able to to tell my
story to this man that I didn't know we
put it on YouTube whatever on the
internet and
uh I feel millions of people will be
able to watch this it's like you're
releasing it yes from your from your
subconscious almost yeah exactly exactly
and I do feel I feel a little better I
didn't know it was going to be like this
this but it's I feel better I swear good
for you that's great
yeah but uh if you had your life to live
all over again James what would you have
done different I don't I wouldn't change
nothing I mean I deal with what has
happened I mean made me a stronger
person now I'm no longer um into
homosexuality I mean so I mean you're
not no I mean I As I Grew Older I knew
that it was wrong I knew that that life
wasn't for me so I mean now that you
know they say once homosexual is always
homosexual but I can honestly say my
life was uh
it like paused and I went through this
phase and now that I'm an older man I
mean I'm out of that phase have you been
in love before big mug been in love
before Oh not with a man with a woman
though with a woman
yeah yeah do you have kids I have two
daughters right now they're they're 22
and 191 just graduated last year you
talk to them no
[Music]
me and their mother are on bad terms so
I
mean I would love to get in contact with
them
know you feel like what happened to you
at that second Foster
family kind of derailed your life yes it
did yeah
because it was it was it was it was it
was it was scary because the forer
parents they had they siblings there too
and two of the siblings was like
Monsters really they was like a couple
of years older than me and they they
felt that what they were doing was right
but it wasn't I mean I was handcuffed I
was TI I was
tickled I
was it hurts to talk about it
though this was in Louisiana this was in
Louisiana
yeah yeah
what emotions do you go through um
holding on to these
secrets a lot of emotions
are it's painful I
mean I was I was I was SED off by be
being by myself a lot you know and
thinking that somebody knew thinking
that they would tell people so I mean I
just
I just dealt
with what was coming at me I was just
dealing with
it I just dealing with
it what's been your darkest Point your
lowest point um me trying to commit
suicide out here in California though he
trying to commit suicide when I had went
to jail the police had picked me up and
uh I tried to commit suicide like twice
once I hung myself and it it broke woke
off then I was at a motel and I took a
lot of drugs to O to O but that didn't
work either so here I am still so the
drugs were mainly to escape the yes
Escape reality that was happening to me
mhm your life gets really dark um it was
my darkest darkest days and there not
nobody I can talk to about the
situation and the the the best way was
to end in my life but I'm so glad that I
didn't now that's great how old are you
now I'm 60 60 so you have plenty of
Plenty good years yeah really real real
talk I've been having good years as of
lately though you look healthy yeah so I
mean I'm glad I'm able to speak on my
subject so somebody else can learn from
it well I think it's a much more common
occurrence than you supect and it's more
people don't tell somebody that they've
been you know unless especially a manly
man like myself I feel today uh they
just they die with that that that that
sorrow you know how has it affected your
life you had jobs I had jobs
but it had affected it
tremendously because I wouldn't I didn't
want to be around nobody you know and
then I I I turned off to hustling
streets and then start selling drugs and
you
know
so it do messes up your
life one way or the
other it seems to affect a person's
self-worth
um yes yes cuz I feel like I mean I
feel like I mean some of the stuff that
men has done I mean it just
and
then it seemed like it was my fault too
because the way it happened in Louisiana
I brought it all here to Hollywood you
know so I was blaming some of the stuff
on myself having self
guilt until I really finally realized
that it's it's it's not me you know as I
got older I realized it wasn't
me it's not your fault not my fault and
for me to be able to go to the police
station or no that's
no but today I feel good
man I'm glad speaking about it seems to
lighten your load a little bit it
lighten a whole bunch whole bunch for
real and I still feel like I I I should
have cried but I'm a big boy
now I don't need to do no crying
at least not
now maybe when I see the see it see the
the the the the video yeah the video I
might cry no you'd be proud of yourself
yeah takes a real man to to share this
kind of stuff yes
yes James what what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life uh to be able to speak out on
anything that's that's happened to you
to to be to be able to speak freely of
the good and the bad you
know there a lot of bad happen to a lot
of people's lives they just don't speak
on
it excellent James thank you so much for
sharing your story a lot of Courage
peace thank you
man